декілька потужних вибухів серед білого
дня ці відео облетіли соцмережі вони
зняті в курортній новофедоровці
неподаліків паторії в анексованому
Росією Криму місцеві та відпочивальники
та описують те що сталося
буквально Я буквально вийшла з машини
пішла руки помити і чую земля Пішла я
стою і здається що я чи злетіла чи пішла
вниз це було так страшно мені страшно
было таке враження як від ядерного
грибка такий грибок піднімався
таких було два вибухи все почало падати
довкола валитися
за словами очевиці вибухи відчувалися за
кілька кілометрів від Епіцентру
хлопок струс над потужний будинок каже
здригнувся шибки полетіли дружину
накрила побувало раму Я чесно кажучи не
зрозумів що то відбувається але слава
богу всім сказав на підлогу і повзіть у
ванну пролунали чергові вибухи такі
потужні вже втретті по-третєму разом
місцева адміністрації повідомляє про
одного загиблого та 14 постраждалих А
також про пошкодження понад 60-ти
багатоквартирних будинків
2014-го Росія незаконно анексувала Крим
президент Зеленський у своєму зверненні
наголосив що півострів прямо пов'язаний
із нинішньою війною ця російська війна
проти України і проти всієї вільної
Європи почалась з Криму І має
закінчитись Криму його звільненням
сьогодні неможливо сказати коли це
станеться але ми постійно додаємо
необхідні компоненти у формулу
звільнення Криму Міноборони Росії
заявили про детонації на майданчику для
зберігання боєприпасів вибухи за словами
відомства не були результатом обстрілу а
пов'язані з порушеннями правил пожежної
безпеки Київ свою причетність до події
офіційно заперечує при цьому радник
офісу Зеленського Михайло Подоляк
припустив щодо вибухів могли бути
причетні місцеві партизани
повідомили про знищення на військовому
аеродромі Саки 9-ти російських літаків
при цьому погоджуючись із російською
версією проспалах
щодо пожежі на території аеродрому сакі
в районі населеного пункту на Федорівка
у тимчасово окупованому Росією Криму
Міноборони України не може встановити
причину займання однак вкотре нагадує
про правила пожежної безпеки та заборону
куріння у невстановлених місцях
досі Україна офіційно не проводила
жодної наступальну операцію в Криму а
лише загрожували ударами по Кримському
мосту проте закордонні експерти
схиляються до того що удару завдали
українці
Звісно це були українці ми вже чули це
раніше від росіян ви напевно пам'ятаєте
коли задумав крейсер Москва теж
розповідали подібні історії а насправді
як згодом з'ясувалося Це українці
вразили його ракетою
причина чому українці трохи
висловлюються неоднозначно може це миє
може і не ми оскільки це всі замішані та
страх серед росіян особливо у російських
військових безлакованих у Криму
звертають увагу на те що Українські
війська знаходяться за 200 км від місця
вибуху і за наявну інформацію українська
армії поки не має у своєму розпорядженні
ракет такої дальності дії тим не менше
нью-йорк times також Виходить з того що
вибухи були результатом українського
атаки видання та інші експерти
Припускають що за Ісуса стосували зброю
розроблено В самій Україні
коли мене запитують чи є це ознакою того
що Україна отримала mgm-140 атакамс Я б
сказав що ні це також може бути
українська ракета грім або грімм-2 однак
вона повинна була покладатися на надані
США проти радіолокаційні ракети щоб
пробити діру в російській
протиповітряній обороні
у свою чергу російська сторона не може
звинувачувати Україну в ракетному ударі
по аеродрому Саки в Криму оскільки це
продемонструвало б неефективність
російської системи ППО вважають
Європейські та американські аналітики
Я думаю що це продовження колишньої
стратегії адже ударом по Криму українці
дають зрозуміти росіянам Що ніде на
окуповані українські території не є
безпечним а для росіян Крим це
найважливіша територія яку захоплено
важливіша ніж Донбас
очевидно що Росія не хоче визнавати що
Україна може
э-э завдавати таких ударів чи
здійснювати такі диверсії так глибоко на
російській на території якого Росія
вважає своєю і вважає безпечною для
своїх громадян Тобто це дуже важливий
суттєвий момент оскільки Крим це місце
буде Росія
закликає своїх громадян їхати
відпочивати
визнати що це небезпечне місце означає
вбити курортний сезон означає завдати
дуже серйозної шкоди іміджу Криму як
саме курортного регіону над яким Росія
працювала багато років куди вкладалися
гроші тому я пропускаю що вони
робитимуть усе щоб надалі говорити що
Крим це безпечно їдьте туди відпочивати
але ми бачимо зараз черги на виїзд з
Криму І невідомо як довго оця тенденція
продовжується чи повернеться ті хто
виїхали чи ні Чи поїдуть нові люди
і Імідж іміджував втрата для Росії
звичайно була б надзвичайно велика
набагато більша До речі мені здається
ніж втрата кількох літаків на які там
згоріла очевидно на цьому військовому
летовищі саме психологічний ефект цього
удару для українців психологічний ефект
для Росії та і західних партнерів сказав
його просто дуже важко оцінити таких
випадків просто ще не було за ці півроку
і значна частина українців я так
припускаю судячи з реакцією в соціальних
мережах чекала побачити такі кадри 8
років навіть не півроку від початку
активної агресії а вісім років відколи
почалася анексія Криму на думку
оглядачів у випадку з вибухами в Криму
які затонулим російським крейсером
Москва Росія буде й надалі заперечувати
український слід